joining me now is Sean Bell who's a
retired Vice Marshall and an advisor for
Universal defense and Security Solutions
Sean thanks again for joining us so a
lot of speculation about how Russia is
re-massing and heading into the East do
you think that's what's happening well
first thing I'd always say is I would
never believe what the enemy was saying
about the battlefield deception is a key
part of any War fighting what we can see
is that Russian troops have withdrawn
from Kiev but what the next move is is
very much in Putin's mind and nobody can
read that at the moment what we can read
is satellite imagery is showing very
clearly that there are Russian forces
moving south past kharkiv and also
um the the Airfield at danipri is being
targeted why they're almost certainly
because that's an air resupply route for
Ukraine to get supplies back into the
donbass it's also worth reminding
everybody that donbass the fighting has
been continuing there for 10 years our
attention has been drawn to the capital
and other higher profile places is but
the fighting has never stopped in the
Dom bass and although it might take
Western analyst believe two to three
weeks to get Russian forces re-brigated
ready for the fight there as we're
hearing from some of the Ukrainian
leaders they're expecting the next phase
of fighting to be particularly brutal
and vicious okay well it was interesting
wasn't it that um Boris Johnson was in
Kiev this weekend and announced a whole
host of military aid what do we know
about what he's announced well I think
first of all the native Secretary
General has been trying to coordinate
some of this Aid because there's lots of
well-intentioned efforts to get military
equipment into Ukraine but of course the
danger is you end up with lots of
disparate equipment which doesn't
actually help the ukrainians at all the
one thing that the UK has always been on
the front foot of providing age to
Ukraine over 200 000 items of military
equipment provided the most recent is
the mass Steve armor Personnel carry
shown here which is a very capable
platform blooded in Afghanistan the
challenge when we get bigger equipment
like this there's a lot of talk about
tanks going in as well well is that the
bigger the equipment the more support
you need with it that's just a piece of
equipment a capability is Equipment Plus
spares plus expertise to support plus
ammunition and of course ultimately
training it's not easy driving one of
these things if you send that in how
long will it take someone to learn how
to operate that well it's one thing to
drive it which be relatively quickly
what you're seeing here is the outside
um steel outside of it inside it's
packed normally full of very clever very
highly sensitive equipment which does
take what a lot of training I understand
that a lot of that's been stripped out
for it to be deployed so it's largely
just now male personnel carrier but the
point being these things do take a lot
of time and training before they can be
usefully deployed so well that's my
question now how useful are they and is
this what zelenski actually needs well
what zielinski has said I want weapons
weapons weapons what's pretty clear is
that daily uh Ukrainian forces are
attacked from the air and attack from
the ground so from the air celinski's
regularly asked for a no-fly zone which
at the moment NATO is reluctant to
provide so he needs weapons that can
take out aircraft from Sky there's
around 250 sorties a day being launched
by Russia so that's quite a big threat
on the ground obviously anti-tank
weapons what we have provided the UK is
Javelin and law and star streak weapons
which have proved very very effective in
the hands of ukrainians but it's one
thing providing them but where do they
come from what's the supply you can't
just go into a supermarket and buy these
things they are developed by individual
nations in partnership with their
industry they take years to develop they
then agree a production line to deliver
War stock and some training stock so
undoubtedly we are reducing our training
stock on Warstock which is a political
decision but there's not an endless
supply AI of weapons available and a
final challenge obviously is for
delivery it's one thing to say you're
going to support Ukraine but first of
all you've got to get malware crops to
Europe to the border for example Poland
but once you've got them across the
Polish border you've then got to make
the difficult Journey all the way to the
front line all the way across Ukraine
which of course is increasingly
difficult and dangerous journey and of
course time is at a premium okay Sean
Bell thank you so much pleasure